[Music]
higher education in America is
crushingly expensive college tuition
rates are rising far faster than family
income is colleges are also politically
monochromatic once in school your kids
will submit to brainwashing or they will
suffer when they come home they may have
learned to hate the values you raised
them with the ones you believe in they
may also be addicted to drugs and
alcohol
so obviously the costs of college are
extraordinarily high but it's worth it
we tell ourselves for the education
education is key our kids need to learn
so the question is are they learning
well several years ago a pair of
academic researchers decided to find out
they studied data from a group of more
than 2,000 students enrolled in 4-year
colleges who've been tracked over a
period of years the book that resulted
from all this research was called
academically adrift limited learning on
college campuses among its many findings
45% of students quote did not
demonstrate any significant improvement
in learning over the first two years of
college close to 40 percent didn't learn
anything at all over four years
how did students learn so little well
many of them never really studied 35
percent of students reported spending no
more than five hours a week in academic
preparation overall the study found a 50
percent decline in the number of hours
students spend studying compared to
several decades ago the average
full-time college student now spends
only 2.76 hours a day on all education
related activities going to class
studying all of it and more than twice
as much time shopping eating and
partying multiply this by an entire
country and you wind up with a deeply
ignorant population there has been a
consistent decline in adult literacy in
America over the past 25 years despite
the fact that more kids than ever are
going to college two separate studies by
the National Assessment of adult
literacy found that most college
graduates fall below proficiency in
verbal and quantitative literacy the
majority could not compete simple
cognitive tasks like comparing the
viewpoints in newspaper editorials we're
calculating the cost of food items in
the grocery store a 2005 study found
that only 30
one percent of college graduates could
read and understand a complex book 31
percent surveys of American college
graduates show that they are far more
ignorant than their counterparts in
virtually every other developed nation
in some cases college graduates in this
country got the same test scores as high
school graduates in other countries as
the Educational Testing Service put it
quote a decade ago the skill level of
American adults was judged to be
mediocre now it is below even that this
is a crisis so you would think that
colleges would respond by increasing
academic rigor but the opposite has
happened a survey of the top public
universities in America found that only
nine schools required an economics
course for graduation for example only
five required a survey course in
American history and as one researcher
noted despite lip service given to
multiculturalism fewer than half
required even intermediate study of a
foreign language meanwhile the number of
degrees awarded in Women's and Gender
Studies increased by more than three
hundred percent since 1990 college
classes are getting flimsier college
graduates are getting Dumber but you
would never know it from their grades
which are getting higher in 1983 the
average college GPA in this country was
2.8 it's now over 3.1 great inflation is
everywhere but its most profound at
private schools at Wake Forest for
example in North Carolina
the cumulative GPA for graduating
seniors in 1988 was 2.8 for in 2014 it
was 3.4 nationally the most common grade
given in college courses right now is an
A according to the New York Times about
43% of all letter grades given our a's
only about 10% are D's and F's in other
words more students are failing yet
almost nobody fails kids no less but
their teachers assure them they no more
colleges barely teach yet every year
they increase their fees try that and a
private business you might get indicted
for fraud do it at an American
University and you get billions in
taxpayer subsidies mark Roosevelt is the
president of st. John's College in Santa
Fe
st. John's is one of the only colleges
in America that is still trying to
provide a traditional liberal arts
education centered on the study of great
books mark Roosevelt joins us today
president oh thanks for come on
appreciate it so thanks for having me I
want to talk to you specifically because
I think this is not to promote your
school but I do think st. John's is
different from most universities to me
you've got a different vantage on this
looking at the country how is it
happened that when more people are going
to college than ever before there is a
consistent decline in adult literacy how
did that happen well first of all thank
you for allowing st. John's to join this
conversation we believe in conversation
and civil discourse which is another
thing that as you've pointed out is
unfortunately absent for many yes I
agree Wow we are you've noted that we
were different mr. Carlson we are so
different we may be the most rigorous
college in America our freshmen must
learn ancient Greek our seniors struggle
with quantum physics along the way they
have to take calculus they have to learn
how to do differential equations and
they have to study Hegel and Cara guard
and Karl Marx and Adam Smith so we are
sailing against almost every prevailing
wind in American higher education I do
agree with a lot of what you said at the
beginning that there has been slippage
slippage in rigger slippage in the
demands academically made of students
and we think that is a mistake and we
have no intention of joining that
particular parade in higher education
well good for you I wonder that what you
make of this phenomenon maybe I miss
reading it but as the outcomes decline
become less impressive kids no less when
they graduate rigor declines you would
think colleges would say we're turning
out people who don't know very much only
30% can read a complex book maybe we
want to teach them more but the opposite
seems to be happening why well I'm not
sure that I know the answer to why the
movement towards allowing students to
shape their own curriculum and to be
able to determine their own education is
is part of it a lack of expectations is
another part of it again
not to return to st. John's but that's
what I know best our students read 200
books and I mean 200 serious books over
the course of their education but mr.
Carlson in all honesty we are for very
few folks and we have about 800 students
between two campuses and our students
are very self selecting they know what
they're getting into they know how hard
it's going to be and you know that is a
very serious challenge for a lot of
students and so many cities are not like
that well so maybe you put your finger
on it what you're offering is a
traditional liberal arts education that
would have been familiar to a lot of
well-educated Americans a hundred years
ago now you've got 800 students so I
guess the question is what percentage of
the American population is really suited
for interested in should participate in
a liberal arts education well you know I
honestly believe that there ought to be
a lot of diversity and our educational
offerings you've talked in the
boundaries about career preparation and
there is a place for that there's a
place for people who want to get trained
to do a job even though we also know
from colleges that only about 20% of
students will actually work in something
that they majored in as you may know mr.
Carlson we don't have majors at st.
John's we don't think that life breaks
down into majors so again we're just
very different so you know the liberal
arts education can be described in very
very different things in very different
places at st. John's it's not required
curriculum everybody's taking all of the
same courses and they're all of equal
rigor and equal demands they're in very
small classes you know an average of
about 15 students in a class there's no
place for them to hide and so the rigor
is is is very real and hope it stays
that way
Marko's well thanks a lot ain't
returning us I appreciate it